[Musique]
oh ça a l'air très stylé salut
aujourd'hui c'est plus qu'un casse-tête
c'est un clou Boox c'est une boîte
escape game j'ai bien fait de
venir allez salut c'est l'équipe qui m'
acheter ça parce que soi-disant ils sont
trop simples les castèes d'habitude
c'est censé être le Nautilus du
capitaine Nemo nous avons récemment
trouvé la boîte insubmersible et vous la
tenez entre vos mains n'essayez pas
d'ouvrir les éléments de la boîte par la
force car ils souffent tous en douceur
on est clairement sur un cass-etê
séquentiel petite phase d'observation
qu'est-ce que c'est que ça il faut il
faut enlever cette étiquette j'imagine
pourquoi m'avoir collé une étiquette
chiante à enlever s'il faut l'enlever
alors on a quoi là on a ce truc très
stylé c'est clairement un monstre de
stranger
things oh là là ça bouge des peut-être
pas trop tout touché là directement va
falloir faire gaffe il y a des
inscriptions partout ah il y a marqué
start ici là croyez-moi sur mesure il y
a marqué start ici donc je pense qu'il
faudrait commencer par làentalisme OK ça
ça verrouille quelque chose chose là on
a fait là je sais pas ce que c'est oh
une jolie rayantra sur le
dessus je pas si ça se voit bien là pour
Maré ça a l'air complexe je regarder en
combien de temps faut le faire escape
room in a box 60 à 90 minutes ok je vais
mettre un chrono tiens je vais le
laisser par là voilà 60 à 90 minutes ok
14 ans et plus et c'est produit par qui
ça par ID venture oui alors il y en a
qui pensent que les castettes c'est des
partenariats non c'est donc il lcheton
je suis pas rémunéré un partenariat
c'est pas ça un partenariat c'est ça
justement je voudrais revenir sur un
commentaire que je vois souvent passer
vous vous demandez si j'ai des
techniques de persuasion éthique et
efficace je vais profiter du sponsor du
jour Rif pour vous montrer la puissance
de cette technique alors Rif à la base
c'est beaucoup moins bien que Free mais
on peut quand même persuader des gens à
s'abonner chez eux en leur retournant le
cerveau Rif veut écraser free en ce
moment avec des offres incroyables par
exemple plutôt que de faire comme les
mecs asbin de Free avec leur free box
pop chez Rif c'est la Rif box pop
maintenant pensez à un chiffre entre 1
et 10 faites-le exact 7 bravo vous venez
de battre free le meilleur wifi que tu
peux avoir avec leur freebx c'est le
wifi 6 soit-disant le wifi le plus
rapide le 6 juste en se posant deux
petites secondes on a fait mieux oui
mais Free c'est aussi connu pour
résister à l'inflation avec les forfaits
téléphoniques au prix fixe et bien
regardez ce prix on est d'accord il est
pas fixe encore une fois Frix vous
manipule alors que shérif lorsqu'ils
font la promesse que leurs prix ne
bougeront pas et bien ils bougent
vraiment pas donc voyez la puissance des
mots CQFD les amoureux de l'innovation
ils irront chez Rif pour la couverture
de 5g ils ont ajouté le réseau 3G au
réseau 2G qui existait déjà et Booum de
la 5G personne n'avait fait ça avant eux
ils sont donc innovants là vous vous
dites que ri c'est peut-être pas si mal
et voilà comment avec quelques
techniques on peut faire croire qu'un
opérateur est meilleur que l'autre alors
qu'il suffit juste de regarder le site
en description pour savoir quel est le
meilleur opérateur entre les deux je
vous laisse tirer vos propres
conclusions alors autant Rif ils se sont
bien cassé la tête autant nous aussi on
va se la péter maintenant ici il y avait
marqué start je l'ai vu ici je peux pas
le tourner je P je pense vraiment que
c'est oh on peut appuyer là sur la torte
je pense vraiment que c'est séquentiel
c'est-à-dire que il faut faire une étape
après l'autre donc start ça me semble
être un bon point de départ là on a un
symbole commeci un symbole comme ça il y
a les mêmes symboles qui apparaissent
plusieurs fois quand on bouge les
hélices et comme par hasard ce cercle
vide peut contenir un symbole peut-être
d'autrre je vais mettre ma grosse tête
ok donc ce trou là il peut contenir
trois symboles différents sur ceux qu'il
y a sur le tour et le trou ici là je
suis obligé de mettre ma gros tête aussi
parce que il est bien auudessus il peut
avoir un 2 3 symboles donc chaque trou
peut avoir trois symboles donc je me dis
si on aligne bien les deux trous
ensemble et qu'ils ont la même
symbolique on devrait pouvoir débloquer
quelque chose en tout cas ça devrait
faire plaisir
quoi vous pourriez faire des extraits si
gênants des vidéos castetettes à chaque
fois ce que vous voyez peut-être pas
bien c'est que sous les céliiss il y a
des bouts aussi de forme géométrique
donc qu' on pas trop de sens et du coup
en mettant lui ici et lui là donc
c'est-à-dire les deux trous sur l'un des
deux symboles identiques j'obtiens un
raccord dans la forme géométrique entre
celle qui a sur le bout de l'hélice
celle qui a sur bout de l'hélice est
celle qui est sur la boîte donc est-ce
que cette forme qui fait un peu une
forme c'est un peu le truc du nuccléaire
là à trois branches est-ce que je la
retrouve quelque part ok je je la
retrouve de ce côté-là la forme c'est
exactement la forme qui est vidée dans
le dans le bois et non pas dans le doigt
c'est c'est cette forme là et il y a un
symbole c'est un peu un un grand S
majuscule de quand on était enfant
est-ce que ce grand S majuscule de quand
j'étais enfant je le retrouve ailleurs
il est il était pas sur le côté là où
j'étais ce côté-là il y est pas c'est
presque sûr je vous fais voir de ce
côté-là ici j'ai trois petites lattes
qui bougent là sur cette lat il y a le
petit symbole que j'ai mis dans les
ronds des deux hélices qui y a là je le
récupère là et là vous aurez beaucoup de
mal à le voir mais j'ai des
gradations espèce comme une petite règle
avec des symboles comme s'il fallait que
j'enfonce un certain niveau vous voyez
ce que je veux dire et sur ces trois
symboles sans surprise j'ai le symbole
que j'ai trouvé ici ok je pense qu'on
est sur la méthode il avais marqué start
j'ai commencé avec les hélices j'ai fait
pointer les deux cercles sur le même
symbole identique ça m'a donné une forme
géométrique que j'ai pu retrouver du
côté là de cette espèce de monstre c'est
celui-là qui lui-même contenait un
symbole ce symbole- làà et le symbole
que j'ai mis dans mes deux cercles je
les retrouve sur cette
petitelette
ici qui est gradué et je pense que donc
il y a correspondance ce qui veut dire
donc qu'il faut aussi que je fasse
pareil avec les autreses puisqu'on a
trois AES et que j'ai trouvé qu'il y
avait trois symboles différents qui
marchaient dans les cercles j'active
j'ai pas mis le bah oui ben je suis pas
habitué les gars désolé ça fait combien
de temps qu'on tourne je sais pas ça
fait moins de 10 minutes quoi l' qui
vous mettra au montage faudra rajouter à
St alors en deuxième symbole j'ai quoi
j'ai un espèce de fer à repasser à
l'envers alors euh le faire à repasser à
l'envers je me perds avec les
côtés de la boîte c'est censé me donner
du coup une forme géométrique si c'est
la même méthode en forme géométrique
j'en ai qu'une qui se distingue c'est
celle-ci espèce d'étoile de ninja qu'on
pourrait balancer donc est-ce que j'ai
une espèce d'étoile de ninja qu'on
pourrait balancer oui quelle est la
forme associée un point d'interrogation
très mal fait donc est-ce que ce point
d'interrogation très mal fait je le
retrouve ici oui ce sera le premier OK
maintenant il faut faire le
dernier le dernier c'est une vague
inversée que j'ai vu là et que j'ai ici
quel est mon symbole qui s'est dessiné
en incluant le vide un espèce de mini
sous-marin ouis on dirait un peu ça avec
un une sorte de trois derrière tant que
j'ai tout en tête je vais je vais je
vais
[Musique]
lescaler là j'ai mis je touche plus à
rien parce que ça bouge sinon là j'ai
mis ce qu'il y avait à mettre en tout
cas ça peut me débloquer quelque chose
tout es interconnecté quoi peut-être je
peux tourner ça un peu du coup non ça ça
a l'air d'être connecté de l'autre côté
ça l' d'être traversantant on dira qu'il
a ça ça me fait bouger ça il y a deux
flèches là de ce côté de ce qui bouge il
y a une flèche pour aller vers le haut
ça se trouve fallait faire ça dès le
départ que je peux le monter et le tirer
oui ce oui était chelou là j'ai pu le
monter comme l'indique la flèche et le
tirer ok stylé vous voyez là ça c'est h
monter et tirer ok super peut-être on
peut faire autre chose
ok ça aussi ça
bouge sorte d'épée énorme c'est énorme
c'est plus grand que la boîte ça ça
celui-là il a l'air d'être relié à l'arê
qui est là non ça bouge pas et de ce
côté-là peut-être ça peut-être le
monstre non plus là il y a un symbole de
tortue si j'appuie sur la
tortue comme ici de ce côté là vous
voyez peut-être pas mais là il y a une
une tortue sur la petite aette peut-être
qu'en appuyant là
oui stylé je peux sortir ça il y avait
une tortue avec une main ici et là il y
avait une tortue du coup j'ai appuyé là
ça sorti la tortue qui était là putend
il y a un truc là de dessiner sur la
tortue là sur la tortue et dessiné du
coup moi je voyais que ça il y a des
indices partout je sais pas parce que là
il y a la bouée aussi je l'ai vu
ailleurs ça je sais pas trop à quoi ça
peut servir si je mets ça dans la forme
qui est dessinée là il se passe quoi
j'ai l'impression de tirer quelque chose
là peut-être il faut l'enfoncer plus
profondément ah si là clairement je tire
quelque chose j'ai l'impression que
c'est relié à ça ça fait bouger les
trucs ici un
peu je tire fort mais c'est pas ça
peut-être que je peux débloquer un truc
de l'autre côté non oh il s'est passé ça
ah d'accord ok quand j'ai enlevé le
grand truc long qui é de ce côté ça a
libéré ce truc là là que je peux bouger
maintenant du coup ouais d'accord donc
il va falloir retirer les quatre pour
tout libérer ici et peut-être permettre
à ça de tourner c'estbligé là il y a une
bouée là-dessus la bouée je l'ai vu
juste de ce côté je l'ai vu tout à
l'heure la Boué je l'ai vu là là on a
deux Boué une bouée conique et une bouée
ronde donc comme c'est celle-ci ça veut
dire qu'il faut tourner les roues vers
la gauche la rou vers la gauche ça force
j'ai le droit ou pas vers la droite ça
fait quoi ça force aussi ça bouge
quelque chose ah oui ça bouge un truc au
dus il y a des cliquetit
ok des fois ça clique des fois ça clique
pas et ça me met des symboles au dessus
j'ai des symboles en forme de triangle
un peu voilà là ça a cliqué CIN fois et
après ça et en fait quand ça arrêtait de
cliquer ça m'a passé sur des symboles en
forme de de créneau de Châteaufort on
dirait ça se voit juste
là là ça a cliqué que quatre fois et il
y a un trou et là maintenant c'est des
symboles arrondis est-ce qu'il y a un
endroit où je peux mettre ce genre
d'information ça on a fait ce qu'on
avait à faire ici je pense là je me dis
ça ça m'a donné des informations c'est
pas pour rien parce que il y a il y a
les symboles visuels que j'ai pu compter
et il y a les clics que j'ai compté
aussi ça fait trois informations
différentes je peux les dissocier avec
les formes qu' avait dans la petite
fenêtre qui était là là dans le monstre
ça fait un code à trois chiffres pour
rentrer ça quelque
part ça aurait été logique qu'on est
rentre là-dedans parce que là on a trois
points et comme la roue cranté elle est
là ah ben c'est là c'est clairement là
je pense que c'est là je même pas vu
tout à l'heure quand je regardais l'arrê
le là on a trois roues cranté et j'avais
pas vu sur les roues sont gravé des
numéros mais également les mêmes types
de crine Lage que ce que j'ai vu de
l'autre côté donc c'est pas mal ça c'est
le rond le rond il y en avait deux
faudrait que je le mette sur deux si je
peux oh je peux pas tourner comme je
veux la roue du milieu elle a un endroit
où elle a pas de cran donc si je mets
l'endroit qui a pas de cran devant par
exemple la roue de droite ohà ça fait
bouger ça de ouf par contre donc là on
va clairement débloquer ça si je la mets
devant une roue la côté dans non cranté
je peux tourner la roue comme je veux
mais forcément après quand je vais
retourner la roue pour bouger lui par
exemple ben ça va refaire bouger ça donc
il va falloir prendre en compte les
inclinaisons et et incrémenter les
différences là ça va être chiant
ok là je suis bon là deux ici qure là là
et c'est presque ça mais c'est si c'est
ça
ok donc là je sors un espèce de truc
encore est-ce que je peux enlever la
pieuve
peut-être non plus malheureusement je
faire comme tout à l'heure est-ce que je
peux enlever des un bloqueur peut-être
ça serait super elle vient d'où cette
flèche là ah j'avis pas vu il y
ah ouais tout était si bien
expliqué en fait depuis le monstre il y
avait un trait qui amenait ici aux trois
élèes que je devais bouger et au petit
truc le petit bloqueur que j'ai enlevé à
l'instant en fait donc là moi je suis en
train de jouer avec ça et ça ça me fait
une flèche qui part de l'arrêt jusqu'ici
pour enlever ça là la flèche elle part
depuis ici ah ben elle là lui il est
connecté à ce que j'ai essayé de faire
tout à l'heure avec le symbole et la
tortue il devrait me permettre d'enlever
ça en fait ah ouais j'avais pas
capté et lui je peux l'enlever
maintenant non toujours pas qu'est-ce
que j'ai libéré là ça ça il y a des
flèches pour insérer on avait vu un
endroit où fallait insérer quelque chose
tout à l'heure donc c'était pour
m'indiquer de tirer dessus donc si je le
mets en mode comme ça est-ce que je peux
vraiment pas le mettre
là-dedans oh attends ah j'ai
agripé un truc là j'arrive à sortir
ça c'était ça fallait fallait que j'ose
en fait j'osais pas ah mais par contre
je suis bloqué ensuite il y a le trait
qui va à lui et lui maintenant il peut
sortir et donc forcément de l'autre côté
je viens de libérer un què ça va j'ai
l'impression que ça avance quand même ok
donc il nous en resterait plus qu'un
normal à chaque fois ça me renvoie sur
un autre truc là ça me renvoie sur rien
mais c'est pas grave puisque le 4è on sa
lequel c'est c'est forcément celui-ci
c'est le seul qu'on n pas
fait alorsi il y a des cadenas qui sont
tous fermés j'imagine qu'il faut tous
les ouvrir lui je peux pas le bouger lui
non plus lui oui lui non lui non lui non
ils sont connectés ils sont
interconnectés d'accord ils sont
interconnectés des deux côtés ok là il y
a ces trucs qu'on peut bouger si je les
mets vers le bas ça me permet de bouger
celui-ci qui est relié je le mets vers
le haut je peux plus bouger mais lui
étant vers le haut je peux bouger lui ok
donc là je peux bouger lui si je le
descends maintenant je peux bouger lui
c'est tout si je le remonte je peux
bouger lui c'est tout si je le
redescends je peux bouger lui pas la
partie la plus du du c-etê je suis le
fil ça m'emmène
là logiquement je peux enlever lui ça
c'est les quatre trucs que j'ai enlevé
du coup ici je peux enlever le blour là
je peux
tourner
est-ce que ce serait pas le trésor du
Nautilus regardez l'intérieur de la
bestiole là l'intérieur du Nautilus
c'est une dinguerie le truc là il y
avait donc les ailettes avec les petits
symboles et donc que je mettais dans les
trous et tout ce qui me renvoyait de ce
côté-là où je voyais les formes à
l'intérieur et donc d'autres symboles ce
qui m'a permis en fait de les mettre sur
ces trucs là sur ces espèce de chos là
là je pouvais tirer dessus et les régler
et quand je vous parlais des fils vous
voyez là ça fait un trait et ce trait il
va en dessous et c'est ce qui m'a
indiqué qu'il peut débloquer ça bon on a
ça à ouvrir j'imagine maintenant parce
qu'il y a un petit bout de papier dedans
on a quand même bien envie de savoir ce
qu'il a sur le petit bout de papier doit
être à 40 minutes avec le début ok ça ça
bouge de haut en bas al comment ça
savoir si ça va de haut en bas ah mais
attends mais ça ça ça doit correspondre
attendez bougez pas nouvelle théorie du
fabou la petite forme que vous voyez là
juste ici au bout d'un l'un des des BL
au cœur ça va parfaitement avec
l'arrondi qu'il y a ici donc je vais le
mettre à l'intérieur et si je le mets à
l'intérieur il y a une petite flèche qui
me dit
ou ça marche que dans un sens évidemment
d'aller vers la gauche donc lui c'est
fait lui ça devait être lui et il me dit
d'aller vers la
droite lui vers la droite OK et enfin
lui dans ce sensl donc vers la droite
aussi ok est-ce que il se passe quelque
chose oui ça se dévisse
monsieur c'est vraiment très agréable
les petitchot de dopamine là quand tu as
un truc qui s'ouvre c'est quand même
assez incroyable allez décoince-toi
Michel je l'appelle Michel mais je sais
pas si c'est son vrai
nom
mobilisinmobily.net ça c'est c'est un
site internet à priori n m o Nemo je
viens de trouver ça donc on va aller sur
le site internet on va voir ce que ça
dit h pass SW ça doit être ça et donc il
y a peut-être un petit système de si
ouais ça s'emboite parfaitement quand
même donc si on l'emboî comme ça
parfaitement sur le message dans les
trou je devrais pouvoir lire des lettres
ATL a NT atlante oui bon
Atlantique n'a pas l'air d'être le bon
mot de
passe il y a pas en français ah si c'est
bon on a un message du capitaine Nemo
mais moi je savais pas qu' il avait
Internet le capitaine Nemo et là on peut
envoyer un petit message pour dire qu'on
l'a réussi incroyable j'ai adoré ça ça
fait combien de temps qu'on est dessus
ça fait 35 minutes qu'on est dessus
moins le temps que j'avais oublié au
départ quand j'avais oublié de lancer le
chrono j'ai remis le tube à l'intérieur
mais j'ai pas laissé le papier dedans à
la place j'ai mis la la clé de
l'appartement de loï et comme ça je vais
lui donner le le cassetê voir en combien
de temps il arrive à récupérer la clé
pour rentrer chez lui je l'ai trouvé
très stylé hein je sais pas pour vous
mais personnellement j'ai trouvé très
intéressant je pense que si ils en ont
d'autres dans la gamme si on en fait
d'autres benah dites-moi d'ailleurs si
vous voulez en faire d'autres
j'utiliserai mieux cette caméra pour
vous faire voir les éléments au fur et à
mesure pour que vous voyez bien dès
qu'il y a un truc de marqué là par
exemple derrière non c'était cette
plaque qui a marqué je m'appelle
toujours Fabian licard à très bientôt
Ciao